my name is Michelle callous and I'm a
professor in the Department of Genetics
at Stanford Medical School I was an
undergraduate at Oxford which is has a
very traditional zoology program and so
I emerged from that and really loving
all the different aspects of biology
from animal behavior to ecology and I
ended up choosing Harvard to do my
graduate work and worked with Wally
Gilbert there while I was there he
actually developed a method to determine
the sequence of DNA
it was developed simultaneously with the
Sanger method in England I had always
wanted to work with human cells but when
I got into science the methods for
working with human cells were very
imprecise and so I kind of had to wait
for the right moment and let those
methods develop before I could do what I
wanted to do and it was around that time
that the genetics department at Stanford
was looking for an assistant professor
that was interested in human genetics
the lab gradually evolved and started to
work with gene therapy and the methods
we were developing fit very nicely into
what was needed to make gene therapy
work you know so we have as our real
mission is to apply the methods of
genetics to cure human disease I'd say
most people don't have very much
understanding of what goes on in you
know current biological research and
it's wonderful that people are
interested in finding out how genetics
works